The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open CourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT Open CourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Hey, everybody.
Let's get going.
Who here has heard of the FFT?
That's most of you.
So I first met
Steve Johnson when
he worked with one of
my graduate students,
now former graduate
student, Matteo Frigo.
And they came up with a
really spectacular piece
of performance
engineering for the FFT,
a system they call FFTW
for the Fastest Fourier
Transform in the West.
And it has, for
over years and years
been a staple of anybody
doing signal processing will
know FFTW.
So anyway, it's a great pleasure
to welcome Steve Johnson, who
is going to talk
about some of the work
that he's been doing
on dynamic languages,
such as Julia and Python.
STEVEN JOHNSON: Yeah.
Thanks.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Is that pretty actuate?
STEVEN JOHNSON: Yeah.
Yeah, so I'm going to talk, as
I said, about high level dynamic
languages and how you
get performance in these.
And so most of you have probably
used Python, or R, and Matlab.
And so these are really
popular for people
doing in technical computing,
statistics, and anything
where you want kind of
interactive exploration.
You'd like to have a
dynamically typed language where
you can just type x equals 3.
And then three lines later,
you said, oh, x is an array.
Because you're doing
things interactively.
You don't have to be stuck
with a particular set of types.
And there's a lot of
choices for these.
But they usually
hit a wall when it
comes to writing
performance critical code
in these languages.
And so traditionally, people
doing some serious computing
in these languages have
a two-language solution.
So they do high
level exploration,
and productivity and so
forth in Python or whatever.
But when they need to write
performance critical code,
then you drop down to a lower
level language, Fortran,
or C, or Cython, or
one of these things.
And you use Python as the glue
for these low level kernels.
And the problem--
and this is workable.
I've done this myself.
Many of you have
probably done this.
But when you drop down from
Python to C, or even to Cython,
there there's a huge
discontinuous jump
in the complexity of the coding.
And there's usually
a lot of generality.
When you write code in C
or something like that,
it's specific to a very
small set of types,
whereas the nice thing
about high level languages
is you can write
generic code that works
for a lot of different types.
So at this point, there's often
someone who pops up and says,
oh, well, I did performance
programming in Python.
And everyone knows you just need
to vectorize your code, right?
So basically, what
they mean is you
rely on mature
external libraries
that you pass on a
big block of data.
It does a huge amount of
computation and comes back.
And so you never
write your own loops.
And this is great.
If there's someone who's already
written the code that you need,
you should try and leverage
that as much as possible.
But somebody has to write those.
And eventually, that
person will be you.
And because eventually if
you do scientific computing,
you run into a problem
inevitably that you just
can't express in terms of
existing libraries very
easily or at all.
So this was the state of
affairs for a long time.
And a few years ago, starting
in Alan Edelman's group at MIT,
there was a proposal for
a new language called
Julia, which tries to be as
high level and interactive
as-- it's a dynamically typed
language, you know, as Matlab,
or Python, and so forth.
But general purpose
language like
Python, very productive
for technical work,
so really oriented towards
scientific numerical computing.
But you can write
a loop, and you
write low level code
in that that's as fast
as C. So that was the goal.
The first release was in 2013.
So it's a pretty young language.
The 1.0 release was in
August of this year.
So before that point
every year there
was a new release,
0.1, 0.2, Point3.
And every year, it would
break all your old code,
and you'd have to update
everything to keep it working.
So now they said,
OK, it's stable.
We'll add new features.
We'll make it faster.
But from this point
onwards, for least
until 2.0, many
years in the future
it will be backwards compatible.
So there's lots of--
in my experience, this
pretty much holds up.
I haven't found
any problem where
there was a nice highly
optimized C or Fortran code
where I couldn't
write equivalent
code or equivalent performance,
equivalently performing
code in Julia given
enough time, right?
Obviously, if something is--
there's a library with
100,000 lines of code.
It takes quite a
long time to rewrite
that in any other language.
So there are lots of benchmarks
that illustrate this.
The goal of Julia is usually to
stay within a factor of 2 of C.
In my experience, it's
usually within a factor
of a few percent if you
know what you're doing.
So there's a very simple
example that I like to use,
which is generating
a Vandermonde matrix.
So giving a vector a value as
alpha 1 alpha 2 to alpha n.
And you want to make an n by m
matrix whose columns are just
those entries to 0 with power,
first power squared, cubed,
and so forth element-wise.
All right, so this
kind of matrix
shows up in a lot of problems.
So most matrix and
vector libraries
have a built in function
to do this and Python.
In NumPy, there is a function
called numpy.vander to do this.
And if you look at--
it's generating a big matrix.
It could be
performance critical.
So they can implement
it in Python.
So if you look at the
NumPy implementation,
it's a little Python shim
that calls immediately to C.
And then if you
look at the C code--
I won't scroll
through it-- but it's
several hundred lines of code.
It's quite long and complicated.
And all that several
hundred lines of code
is doing is just figuring
out what types to work with,
like what kernels
to dispatch to.
And at the end of that,
it dispatches to a kernel
that does the actual work.
And that kernel is also
C code, but that C code
was generated by a special
purpose code generation.
So it's quite involved
to get good performance
for this while still being
somewhat type generic.
So their goal is
to have something
that works for basically any
NumPy array and any NumPy type,
which there's a
handful, like maybe
a dozen scalar types that it
should work with, all right?
So if you're
implementing this in C,
it's really trivial to write 20
lines of code that implements
this but only for double
precision, a point or two
double position
array, all right?
So the difficulty is
getting type generic in C.
So in Julia.
Here is the
implementation in Julia.
It looks at first glance
much like what roughly
what a C or Fourier
implementation would look like.
It's just implemented
the most simple way.
It's just two nested loops.
So just basically,
you loop across.
And as you go across,
you accumulate powers
by multiplying repeatedly by x.
That's all it is.
And it just fills in the array.
The performance
of that graph here
is the time for the NumPy
implementation divided
by the time for the
Julie implementation
as a function of n
for an n by n matrix.
The first data point,
I think there's
something funny going on
that's not 10,000 times slower.
But for a 10 by
10, 20 by 20 array,
the NumPy version is
actually 10 times slower
because it's basically the
overhead that's imposed by all
going through all those layers.
Once you get to
100 by 100 matrix,
the overhead doesn't matter.
And then it's all this optimized
C code, generation and so forth
is pretty much the same
speed as the Julia code.
Except the Julia code
there, as I said,
it looks much like C code
would, except there's no types.
It's Vander x.
There's no type declaration.
x can be anything.
And, in fact, this works
with any container type
as long as it has an
indexing operation.
And any numeric type--
it could be real numbers.
It could be complex numbers.
It could be quarternians,
anything that
supports the times operation.
And there's also a call to 1.
So 1 returns the multiplicative
identity for whatever,
so whatever group you're in
you need to have a 1, right?
That's the first column.
That might be a different type
of 1 for a different object,
right?
It might be an array of
matrices, for example.
And then the 1 is
the identity matrix.
So, in fact.
There are even cases
where you can do.
Get significantly faster than
optimize C and Fortran codes.
So I found this when I was
implementing special functions,
so things like the error
function, or polygamma
function, or the inverse
of the error function.
I've consistently found
that I can get often
two to three times faster
than optimized C and Fortran
libraries out there, partly
because I'm smarter than people
who wrote those libraries,
but-- no-- mainly
because in Julia,
I'm using basically
the same expansions, the same
series, rational functions
that everyone else is using.
The difference is
then in Julia, it
has built-in
techniques for what's
called metaprogramming
or co-generation.
So usually, the
special functions
involved lots of
polynomial evaluations.
That's what they boil down to.
And you can basically
write co-generation
that generates very
optimized inline evaluation
of the specific polynomials
for these functions that
would be really awkward
to write in Fortran.
You'd either have to
write it all by hand
or write a separate routine,
a separate program that
wrote Fortran code for you.
So you can do this.
It's a high level languages
allow you to do tricks
for performance that it would be
really hard to do in low level
languages.
So mainly what I
wanted to talk about
is give some idea of
why Julia can be fast.
And to understand
this, you also need
to understand why
is Python slow.
And in general, what's going on
in determining the performance
in a language like this?
What do you need in the language
to enable you to compile it
to fast code while still,
still being completely
generic like this
Vander function, which
works on any type.
Even user-defined, numeric type,
user-defined container type
will be just as fast.
There's no privileged-- in
fact, if you look at Julia,
almost all of Julia is
implemented in Julia.
Integer operations and things
like that, the really basic
types, most of that is
implemented in Julia, right?
Obviously, if you're
multiplying two 32-bit integers.
At some point, it's calling an
assembly language instruction.
But even that, calling
out to the assembly
is actually in Julia.
So at this point, I
want to switch over
to sort of a live calculation.
So this is from a
notebook that I developed
as part of a short course
with Alan Edelman, who's
sitting over there, [INAUDIBLE]
on performance optimization
high level languages.
And so I want to go through
just a very simple calculation.
Of course, you would never--
in any language, usually you
would have a built-- often
have a built-in
function for this.
But it's just a sum function
just written up there.
So we need to have a list,
an array, of n numbers.
We're just going to add them up.
And if we can't make this fast,
then we have real problems.
And we're not going to be able
to do anything in this list.
So this is the
simple sort of thing
where if someone doesn't
provide this for you,
you're going to have to
write a loop to do this.
So I'm going to look at it
not just in Julia but also
in Python, in C, and Python
with NumPy and so forth.
So this document that
I'm showing you here
is a Jupyter Notebook.
Some of you may have
seen this kind of thing.
So Jupyter is this really nice--
they provide this really
nice browser-based front end
when I can put in equations,
and text, and code, and results,
and graphs all in one
Mathematical notebook document.
And you can plug in
different languages.
So initially, it was for Python.
But we plugged in Julia.
And now there's R, and
there's 30 different--
like 100 different
languages that you can
plug in to the same front end.
OK, so I'll start with the
C implementation of this.
So this is a Julia
notebook, but I can easily
compile and call
out to C. So I just
made a string that
has just-- you
know there's 10 lines
C implementation.
It's just the most
obvious function
that just takes in a pointer
to an array of doubles
and it's length.
And it just loops over
them and sums them up,
just what you would do.
And then I'll compile it
with GCC dash 03 and link it
to a shared library, and load
that shared library in Julia
and just call it.
So there's a function
called C call in Julia where
I can just call out to a C
library with a 0 overhead,
basically.
So it's nice because you have
lots of existing C libraries
out there.
You don't want to lose them.
So I just say C call, and
we call this c_sum function
in my library.
It returns a flow 64.
It takes two parameters,
a size t and a flow 64.
And I'm going to pass
the length of my array.
And the array-- and
it'll automatically--
a Julia array, of course,
is just a bunch of numbers.
And it'll pass a pointer
to that under the hood.
So do that.
And I wrote a little
function to call
relerr that computes
the relative error
between the fractional
difference between x and y.
And I'll just check it.
I'll just generate 10 to
the 7 random numbers in 01
and compare that to the Julia
because Julia has a built-in
function called sum,
that sums and array.
And it's giving the same answer
to 13 decimal places, so not
quite machine precision, but
there's 10 to the 7 numbers.
So the error is
kind of accumulative
when you add it across.
OK so, as I'm calling it,
it's giving the right answer.
And now I want to just
benchmark the C implementation,
use that as kind of
a baseline for this.
This should be pretty fast
for an array of floating point
values.
So there's a Julia package
called benchmark tools.
As you probably know
from this class,
benchmarking is a
little bit tricky.
So this will take something,
run it lots of times,
collect some statistics,
return the minimum time,
or you can also get the
variance and other things.
So I'm going to get that number.
B time is something
called a macro in Julia.
So it takes an
expression, rewrites it
into something that basically
has a loop, and times it,
and does all that stuff.
OK, so it takes 11 milliseconds
to sum 10 to the 7 numbers
with a straight C, C loop
compiled with jcc-03,
no special tricks, OK?
And so that's 1
gigaflop, basically,
billion operations per second.
So it's not hitting the
peak rate of the CPU.
But, of course, there's
additional calculations.
This array doesn't fit
in cache, and so forth.
OK.
So now let's-- before
I do anything in Julia,
let's do some Python.
But I'll do a trick.
I can call Python from
Julia, so that way
I can just do everything from
one notebook using a package I
wrote called PyCall.
And PyCall just calls
directly out to lib Python.
So with no virtually
no overhead, so
it's just like calling
Python from within Python.
I'm calling directly out to
lib Python functions to call.
And I can pass any type I
want, and call any function,
and do conversions
back and forth.
OK, so I'm going
to take that array.
I'll convert it to a
Python list object.
So I don't want to time
the overhead of converting
my array to a Python array.
So I'll just convert
ahead of time.
And just start with a built--
Python has a built-in
function called sum.
So I'll use the
built-in sum function.
And I'll get this
Py object for it.
I'll call it PySum
on this list and make
sure it's giving the right
answer OK is the difference is
10 to the minus 13 again.
And now let's benchmark it.
Oops.
There we go.
So it takes a few
seconds because it
has to run it a few times
and catch up with statistics.
OK, so it takes 40 milliseconds.
That's not bad.
It's actually it's four or
five times slower than C,
but it's pretty good, OK?
So and why is it five
times slower than C?
Is it is it because--
the glib answer is, oh,
well, Python is slow
because it's interpreted.
But the sum function
is actually written
in C. Here's the C
implementation of the sum
function that I'm calling.
And I'm just linking
to the GitHub code.
There's a whole
bunch of boilerplate
that just checks with
the type of the object,
and then has some
loops and so forth.
And so if you look
carefully, it turns out
it's actually doing really well.
And the reason it does really
well is it has a fast path.
If you have a list where
everything is a number type,
so then it has an optimized
implementation for that case.
But it's still five
times slower than C.
And they've spent a
lot of work on it.
It used to be 10 times slower
than C a couple of years ago.
So they do a lot of
work on optimizing this.
And so why aren't they
able to get C speed?
Since they have a C
implementation of a sum,
are they just dumb, you know?
No.
It's because the
semantics of the data type
prevent them from getting
anything faster than that.
And this is one
of the things you
learn when you do high level
performance in high level
languages.
You have to think
about data types,
and you have to think about
what the semantics are.
And that that greatly constrains
what any conceivable compiler
can do.
And if the language
doesn't provide you
with the ability to
express the semantics
you want, then you're dead.
And that's one of the basic
things that Julia does.
So what does a Python list?
Right, so you have-- you
can have three, four, right?
A Python list is a bunch
of objects, Python objects.
But the Python numbers
can be anything.
They can be any type.
So it's completely
heterogeneous types.
So, of course, a particular
list like in this case
can be homogeneous.
But the data structure
has to be heterogeneous
because, in fact, I can
take that homogeneous thing.
At any point, I can assign
the third element to a string,
right?
And it has to support that.
So think about what that
means for how it has
to be implemented in memory.
So what this has to do--
so this is a list of--
in this case, three items.
But what are those items?
So if they can be
an item of any type,
they could be things that-- they
could be another array, right?
It could be of different
sizes and so forth.
You don't want to have an
array where everything is
a different size, first of all.
So it has to be this
an array of pointers
where the first pointer
is 3, turned out to be 3.
The next one is four.
The next one is 2, all right?
But it can't just be that.
It can't just be pointer to--
if this is a you
64-bit number, it's
can't just be pointer to
one 64-bit value in memory,
because it has to know.
It has to somehow store
what type the subject is.
So there has to be a type tag
this says this is an integer.
And this one has to have a type
tag that says it's a string.
So this is sometimes
called the box.
So you have a value, you
have a type tag plus a value.
And so imagine what even the
most optimized C imitation
has to do given this
kind of data structure.
OK, here's the first element.
It has to chase the pointer and
then ask what type of object
is it, OK?
Then depending on
what type of object
is it, so I initialize
my sum to that.
Then I read the next object.
I have to chase the second
pointer, read the type tag,
figure out the type.
This is all done
at run time, right?
And then, oh, this
is another integer
that tells me I want to use the
plus function for two integers,
OK?
And then I read the next
value, which maybe--
which plus function
it's using depends
upon the type of the object.
It's an to
object-oriented language.
I can define my own type.
If it has its own plus function,
it should work with sum.
So it's looking up the types
of the objects at runtime.
It's looking at the plus
function at runtime.
And not only that, but each
time it does a loop iteration it
has to add two things
and allocate a result.
That result in general
might be another--
it has to be a box because
the type might change
as you're summing through.
If you start with integers, and
then you get a floating point
value, and then you get an
array, the type will change.
So each time you do
a loop iteration,
it allocates another box.
So what happens is the C
implementation is a fast path.
If they're all
integer types, I think
it doesn't reallocate
that box for the sum it's
accumulating all the time.
And it caches the value of
the plus function it's using.
So it's a little bit faster.
But still, it has to
inspect every type tag
and chase all these pointers
for every element of the array,
whereas the C
implementation of sum,
if you imagine what this
is this compiles down to,
for each loop iteration,
what does it do?
It increments a pointer
to the next element.
At compile time, the
types are all flow 64.
So it flushes flow 64
value into a register.
And then it has a running
sum in another register,
calls one machine instruction
to add that running sum,
and then it checks
to see if we're done,
an if statement there, and
then goes on, all right?
So just a few instructions
and in a very tight loop here,
whereas each loop
iteration here has
to be lots and lots
of instructions
to chase all these pointers
to get the type tag--
and that's in the fast case
where they're all the same type
and it's optimized for that.
So where was I?
So wrong thing.
So that's the
Python sum function.
Now most many of
you, you've used
Python know that there
is another type of array
and there's a whole
library called NumPy
for working with numerics.
So what problem is
that addressing?
So the basic problem
is this data structure.
This data structure, as soon
as you have a list of items--
it can be any type--
you're dead, right?
There's no way to make
this as fast as a C
loop over a double pointer.
So to make it
fast, what you need
to have is a way to say, oh,
every element of this array
is the same type.
So I don't need to store
type tags for every element.
I can store a type tag
once for the whole array.
So there, there is a tag.
There is a type, which
is, say, float 64, OK?
There is maybe a
length of the array.
And then there's just a bunch
of values one after the other.
So this is just 1.0, 3.7, 8.9.
And each of these are just 8
bytes, an 8-byte double in C
notation, right?
So it's just one
after the other.
So it reads this once,
reads the length,
and then it dispatches
to code that says,
OK, now-- basically dispatches
to the equivalent of my C code,
all right?
So now once it knows the
type and the length, then OK,
it says it runs this, OK?
And that can be quite fast.
And the only problem
is you cannot write,
implement this in Python.
So Python doesn't
provide you a way
to have that semantics
to have a list of objects
where you say they all
have to be the same type.
There is no way to
enforce that, or to inform
the language of that in Python.
And then to tell
it-- oh, for this,
since these are
all the same type,
you can throw away the boxes.
Every Python object
looks like this.
So there's no way
to tell Python.
Oh, well, these are
all the same types.
You don't need to
store the type tags.
You don't need to have pointers.
You don't need to have
reference counting.
You can just slam the
values into memory one
after the other.
It doesn't provide you
with that facility,
and so there's no way to--
you can make a fast Python
compiler that will do this.
So NumPy is implemented
in C. Even with--
some of you are
familiar with PyPy,
which is an attempt to make
a fast-- like a tracing
jit for Python.
So when they poured
into NumPy to PyPy,
or they attempted to, even then
they could implement more of it
in Python.
But they had to
implement the core in C.
OK, but given that,
I can do this.
I can import the NumPy
module into Julia,
get its sum function, and
benchmark the NumPy sum
function, and--
OK, again, it takes
a few seconds to run.
OK, and it takes
3.8 milliseconds.
So the C was 10 milliseconds.
So it's actually doing
faster than the C
code, almost a little over
twice as fast, actually.
And what's going on is their C
code is better than my C code.
Their C code is using
SIMD instructions.
So and at this point, I'm
sure that you guys all
know about these
things where you
can read in two numbers or four
numbers into one giant register
and one instruction add
all four numbers at once.
OK, so what about if we
go in the other direction?
We write our own
Python sum function.
So we don't use the Python
sum implemented in C.
I write our own Python.
So here is a little my
sum function in Python.
Only works for floating point.
Oh, I initialize S to 0.0.
So really, it only accumulates
floating point values.
But that's OK.
And then I just
loop for x and a,
s equals s plus x, return s
is the most obvious thing you
would write in Python.
OK, and checked that it works.
Yeah, errors 10 the minus 13th.
It's giving the right answer.
And now let's time it.
So remember that C
was 10 milliseconds.
NumPy was 5 milliseconds, and
then built-in Python was like,
the sum was 50 milliseconds
operating on this list.
So now we have C code
operating on this list
with 50 milliseconds.
And now we have Python code
operating on this list.
And that is 230
milliseconds, all right?
So it's quite a bit slower.
And it's because, basically,
in Python, there's--
in the pure Python
code, there's no way
to implement this fast
path that checks--
oh they're all the same
type, so I can cash
the plus function and so forth.
I don't think it's
feasible to implement that.
And so basically
then on every loop
iteration has to look up the
plus function dynamically
and allocate a new
box for the result
and do that 10 to 7 times.
Now, so there's a built-in
sum function in Julia.
So [INAUDIBLE] benchmark
that as a-- it's actually
implemented in Julia.
It's not implemented
in C. I won't
show you the code
for the built-in one
because it's a little
messy because it's actually
computing the sum more
accurately than the loop that
have done.
So that's 3.9 milliseconds.
So it's comparable to
the NumPy code, OK?
So it's also using SIMD,
but so this is also fast.
So now so why can Julie do that?
So it has to be that the
array type, first of all,
has the type attached to it.
So you can see the type of the
array is an array of low 64.
So there's a type tag
attached to the array itself.
So somehow, that's involved.
So it looks more
like an NumPy ray
in memory than a Python list.
You can make the
equivalent of a Python list
that's called an array of any.
So if I convert this to an
array of any, so an array of any
is something where the elements
types can be any Julia type.
And so then it has to
be stored as something
like this as an array
of pointers to boxes.
And when I do that--
let's see-- [INAUDIBLE]
there it is--
then it's 355 milliseconds.
So it's actually even
worse than Python.
So the Julia-- the
Python, they spent a lot
of time optimizing
their code past
for things that had to allocate
lots of boxes all the time.
So in Julia, it's
usually understood
that if you're
writing optimized code
you're going to do it not on
arrays of pointers to boxes.
You're going to write on
homogeneous arrays or things
where the types are
known at compile time.
OK, so let's write our
own Julia sum function.
So this is a a
Julia sum function.
There's no type declaration.
It works on any container type.
I initialize s for
this function called 0
for the element type of a.
So it initializes into
the additive identity.
So it will work on any
container of anything
that supports a plus function
that has an additive identity.
So it's completely generic.
It looks a lot like
the Python code
except for there's no
0 function in Python.
And let's make sure it
gives the right answer.
It does.
And let's benchmark it.
So this is the code you'd
like to be able to right.
You'd like to be able to
write high level code that's
a straight level straight loop.
Unlike the C code, it's
completely generic, right?
It works on any
container, anything
you can loop over, and anything
that has a plus function, so
an array of quarternians
or whatever.
And a benchmark,
it's 11 milliseconds.
It's the same as the C code
I wrote in the beginning.
It's not using SIMD.
So the instructions are--
that's where the additional
factors of 2 come.
But it's the same as
the non SIMD C code.
And, in fact, if I
want to use SIMD,
there is a little tag you
can put on a loop to tell--
it says compile this with llvm.
Tell llvm to try and
vectorize the loop.
Sometimes it can.
Sometimes it can't.
But something like
this, it should
be able to vectorize
it simple enough.
You don't need to hand code
SIMD instructions for a loop
this simple.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why don't you
always put the [INAUDIBLE]??
STEVEN JOHNSON: So a yeah,
why isn't it the default?
Because most code, the
compiler cannot autovectorize.
So it increases the completion
time and often blows
to the code size for no benefit.
So it's only really--
it's really only
relatively simple loops
on doing simple operations and
arrays that benefit from SIMD.
So you don't want
it to be there.
Yeah, so now it's
4.3 milliseconds.
So it's about the same as
the NumPy and so forth.
It's a little slower
than the NumPy.
It's interesting.
A year ago when I tried
this, it was almost exactly
the same speed as the NumPy.
And then since then, both
the NumPy and the Julia
have gotten better.
But the NumPy got better more.
So there's something
going on with basically
how well the compiler can
use AVX instructions by--
it seems like we're still
investigating what that is.
But it's an llvm
limitation looks like.
So as it's still
completely type generic.
So it I make a random
array of complex numbers,
and then I sum them--
which one am I calling now?
Am I calling the vector?
My sum is the
vectorized one, right?
So complex numbers--
each complex number
is two floating point numbers.
So it should take
about twice the time
to naively think, right?
So twice the number
of operations to add,
the same number of
complex numbers,
the same number of real numbers.
Yeah, and it does.
It takes about 11 milliseconds.
So 10 to the 7, which
is about twice the 5
milliseconds it took for the
same number of real numbers.
And the code works
for everything.
So why?
OK, so what's going on here?
So-- OK, so we saw
this my sum function.
I'll just take out
the SIMD for now.
And we did all that.
OK.
OK, and it works for any type.
It doesn't even
have to be an array.
So, for example, there
is another container type
called a set in Julia, which
is just an unordered collection
of unique elements.
But you can also loop over it.
If it's a set of integers,
you can also summit.
And I'm waiting for the
benchmarks to complete.
So let me allocate a set.
It says there's no
type declarations here.
Mysum a-- there was
no a-- has to be
an array of particular
type or it doesn't even
have to be an array, right?
So set is a different
data structure.
And so it's a set of integers.
The sets are unique.
If I add something to already
the set-- it's in there--
it won't add it twice.
And it supports
the fast checking.
Is 2 in the set?
Is 3 in the set?
It doesn't have to look
through all the elements.
It's a hash internally.
But I can call my
mysum function on it,
and it sums up 2 plus 17 plus
6.24, which is hopefully 49,
right?
So OK, so what's going on here?
So suppose you define--
the key, one of
the keys, there's
several things that are going
on in to make Julia fast.
One key thing is that when
you have a function like this
mysum, or even here's
a simpler function--
f of x equals x plus 1--
when I call it with a
particular type of argument,
like an integer, or
an array of integers,
or whatever, then it compiles
a specialized version
of that for that type.
So here's f of x
equals x plus 1.
It works on any type
supporting plus.
So if I call f of 3--
so here I'm passing
a 64-bit integer.
When it did that, it says,
OK, x is a 64-bit integer.
I'm going to compile
a specialized version
of f with that knowledge.
And then when I call with
a different type, 3.1,
now x is a floating
point number.
It will compile a specialized
version with that value.
If I call it with
another integer,
it says, oh, that version
was already compiled.
[INAUDIBLE] I'll re-use it.
So it only compiles
it the first time
you call it with
a particular type.
If I call it with
a string, it'll
give an error because
it doesn't know
how to add plus to a string.
So it's a particular--
OK, so what is going on?
So we can actually look
at the compiled code.
So the function is called
code, these macros called code
llvm and code native.
They say, OK, when I
call f of 1, what's the--
do people know what llvm is?
You guys-- OK, so llvm
compiles to byte code first
and then it goes
to machine codes.
So you can see the
llvm bit code or byte
code, or whatever it's called.
And you can see the
native machine code.
So here's the llvm
byte code that it
compiles to [INAUDIBLE].
So it's a bit called
add i640 basically
one llvm instruction, which
turns into one machine
instruction, load effective
address is actually
a 64-bit edition
function instruction.
So let's think about
what had to happen there.
So you have f of
x equals x plus 1.
Now you want to compile for x
is a int 64, so 64-bit integer,
or in Julia, we'd say
x colon colon int 64.
So colon colon means that
this is of this type, OK?
So this is 64-bit integer type.
So what does it have to do?
It first has to figure out
what plus function to call.
So plus, it has lots of--
there is a plus for
two matrices, a plus
for lots of different things.
So depending on the
types of the arguments,
it decides on which
plus function to call.
So it first realizes,
oh, this is an integer.
Oh, this is an integer.
This is also a 64-bit integer.
So that means I'm going to
call the plus function for two
integers.
So I'm going to look
into that function.
And then, oh, that
one returns an int 64.
So that's a return
value for my function.
And oh, by the
way, this function
is so simple that I'm
going to inline it.
So it's type specializing.
And this process of going
from x is an integer to that,
to figure out the
type of the output,
is called type inference, OK?
So.
in general, for
type inference, it
is given the types
of the inputs,
it tries to infer the types
of the outputs and, in fact,
all intermediate values as well.
Now what makes it a dynamic
language is this can fail.
So in some languages like
ml or some other languages,
you don't really declare types.
But they're designed
so they could
give the types the inputs.
So you can figure
out everything.
And if it can't
figure out everything,
it gives an error, basically.
It has to infer everything.
So Julia is a dynamic language.
This can fail and
have a fallback.
If it doesn't know the type,
it can stick things in a box.
But obviously, the fast
path is when it succeeds.
And one of the key
things is you have
to try and make this kind
of thing work in a language.
You have to design
the language so
that at least for all
the built-in constructs,
the standard
library, in general,
in the culture for
people designing packages
and so forth, to design things
so that this type inference can
succeed.
And I'll give a counter example
to that in a minute, right?
So and this works recursively.
So it's not suppose
I define a function g
of x equals f of x times 2, OK?
And then I called g of 1.
So it's going to say, OK,
x here is an integer, OK?
I'm going to call f with
an integer argument.
Oh, I should compile f
for an integer argument,
figure out its return
type, use its returned type
to figure out what time's
function to call and do all
of this at compile time, right?
Not at runtime, ideally.
So we can look at the
llvm code for this.
And, in fact, so remember,
f of x adds 1 to x.
And then we're multiplying by 2.
So the result
computes 2x plus 2.
And llvm is smart enough.
So f is so simple
that it inlines it.
And then llvm is smart
enough that I don't have to--
well, I know it does it
by one shift instruction
to multiply x by 2.
And then it adds 2.
So it actually combines
the times 2 and the plus 1.
So it does constant folding, OK?
And it can continue on.
If you look at h of x
equals g of x times 2,
then that compiles to 1 shift
instruction to multiply x by 4
and then adding 4.
So you want the-- so
this process cascades.
So you can even do it
for recursive function.
So here's a stupid
implementation of the Fibonacci
number and calculation of
recursive limitation, right?
So this is given n.
It's an integer.
OK, if n is less
than 3, returns 1.
Otherwise, it adds the
previous two numbers.
I can compute the first
call, listen to the first 10
integers.
Here's the first 10
Fibonacci numbers.
There's also an acute
notation in Julia.
You can say fib dot.
So if you do f dot arguments,
it calls the function element
Y's on a collection and
returns a collection.
So F dot 1 to 10 returns the
first 10 Fibonacci numbers.
And I can call--
there's a function called code
1 type that'll tell me what--
it'll tell me the output
of type inference.
N is a 1.
And it goes through-- this is
kind of a hard to read format.
But this is like the--
after one of the compiler passes
called lowering, but yeah.
It's figure out the types
of every intermediate calls.
So here it's invoking
main dot fib.
It's recursively.
And it's figured out that the
return type is also int 64.
So it knows everything, OK?
So you'll notice that
here I declared a type.
I've said that this
is an integer, OK?
I don't have to do that
for type inference.
This doesn't help
the compiler at all
because it does type inference
depending on what I pass.
So what this is is
more like a filter.
It says that if I pass--
this function only
accepts integers.
If you pass something else,
you should throw an error.
Because if I don't
want this function,
because if I pass 3.7,
if I fill out any number,
if you look at the
3.7, I can check
whether it's less than three.
You can call it recursively.
I mean, the function would run.
It would just give
nonsense, right?
So I want to prevent someone
from passing nonsense for this.
So that's one reason to
do a type declaration.
But another reason is to do
something called dispatch.
So what we can do
is we can define
different versions
of the function
for different arguments.
So. for example.
another nicer version of
that is a factorial function.
So here is a stupid
recursive implementation
of a factorial function that
takes an integer argument
and just recursively
calls itself an n minus 1.
You can call it a
10 factorial, OK?
If I want 100 factorial, I need
to use a different type, not
64-bit integers.
I need some arbitrary
precision integer.
And since I said it was an
integer, if I call in 3.7,
it'll given an error.
So that's good.
But now I can find a
different version of this.
So actually, there
is a generalization
of factorial to arbitrary real,
in fact, even complex numbers
called a gamma function.
And so I can define
a fallback that
works for any type of
number that calls a gamma
function from someplace else.
And then if I can pass it to
floating point value, I can--
if you take the
factorial minus 1/2,
it turns out that's actually
a square root of pi.
So if I square it, it
gives pi, all right?
So now I have one function and
I have two methods, all right?
So these types here, so
there's a hierarchy of types.
So this is what's called
an abstract type, which
most of you have probably seen.
So there's a type called number.
And underneath, there's a class
of subtypes called integer.
And underneath, there is,
for example, int 64 or int 8
for 64-bit integers.
And underneath number
there's actually
another subtype called real.
And underneath that there's
a couple of subtypes.
And then there's say
flow 64 or float 32
for a single precision
32-bit floating
point number and so forth.
So there's a hierarchy
of these things.
When I specify something
can take integer
I'm just saying so this type
is not help the compiler.
It's to provide a filter.
So this method only
works for these types.
And this other
method only works--
my second method works
for any number type.
So I have one thing that
works for any number.
Whoops.
Here it is--
One that works for
any number type,
and one method that
only works for integers.
So when I call it for
3, which ones does it
call, because it actually
called both methods.
And what it does is it
calls the most specific one.
It calls the one that sort
of farthest down the tree.
So if I have a method defined
for number and one defined
for integer, if I pass an
integer, it'll do this.
If I have one that's
defined for number,
one that's defined by
integer, and one that's
defined specifically
for int 8, and I
call it a --pass
an 8 bit integer,
it'll call that
version, all right?
So it gives you a filter.
But, in general, you can do
this on multiple arguments.
So this is like the key
abstraction in Julia, something
called multiple dispatch.
So this was not
invented by Julia.
I guess it was present
in Small Talk, and Dylan.
It's been in a
bunch of languages.
It's been floating
around for a while.
But it's not been in a lot
of mainstream languages,
not in a high performance way.
And you can think of
it as a generalization
of advertising and programming.
So I'm sure all of you have
done object oriented programming
in Python or C++ or
something like this.
So in object-oriented
programming typically
the way you think of it is
this is you save an object.
It's usually spelled object dot
method xy for example, right?
And what it does, is this
type, the object type
determines the method, right?
So you can have a
method called plus.
But it would actually call
a different class function
for a complex number or a real
number, something like that,
or a method called length,
which for a Python list
would call a different function
than for an NumPy array, OK?
In Julia, the way you
would spell the same thing
would you'd say method.
And you wouldn't say
object dot method.
So you don't think of the--
here, you think of the object
as sort of owning the method.
all right?
And Julia-- the
object would just
be maybe the first argument.
In fact, under the hood, if you
looking in Python, for example,
the object is passed as an
implicit first argument called
self, all right?
So it actually is doing this.
It's just different
spelling of the same thing.
But as soon as you read it this
way, you realized what Python
and what op languages
are doing is
they're looking at the
type of the first argument
to determine the method.
But why just the first argument?
In a multiple dispatch language,
you look at all the types.
So this is sometimes-- in
Julia, this will sometimes
be called single dispatch
because determining
the method is called
dispatch, figuring out
which function is spelled
length, which function actually
are you calling this dispatching
to the right function.
So this is called
multiple dispatch.
And it's clearest if you look at
something like a plus function.
So a plus function,
if you do a plus
b, which plus you do really
should depend on both a and b,
right?
It shouldn't depend
on just a or just b.
And so it's actually quite
awkward in languages,
in o op languages like Python
or especially C++ to overload
a plus operation that operates
on sort of mixed types.
As a consequence, for example,
in C++ there's a built-in
complex number type.
So you can have a complex
float, or complex double,
complex and complex with
different real types.
But you can't add a complex
float to a complex double.
You can't add a
single-precision complex number
to a double-precision complex
number or any mixed operation
because--
any mixed complex
operation because it
can't figure out
who owns the method.
It doesn't have a way of
doing that kind of promotion,
all right?
So in Julia, so now
you can have a method
for adding a float
32 to a float 32,
but also a method for adding a--
I don't know-- let's see,
adding a complex number
to a real number, for example.
You want to specialize--
or a real number
to a complex number.
You want to specialize things.
In fact, we can click on the
link here and see the code.
So the complex number to
a real number in Julia
looks like this.
It's the most obvious thing.
It's implemented in Julia.
Plus complex real creates
new complex number.
But you only have to
add the real part.
You can leave the
imaginary part alone.
And this works on
any complex type.
OK, so there's too
many methods for--
OK, I can shrink that.
Let's see.
So but there's another type
inference thing called--
I'll just mention it briefly.
So one of the things you've to
do to make this type inference
process work is given the
types of the arguments
you have to figure out the
type of the return value, OK?
So that means when
you assign a function,
it has to be what's
called type stable.
The type of the
result should depend
on the types of the
arguments and not
on the values of the
arguments because the types
are known at compile time.
The values are only
known at runtime.
And it turns out if you don't
have this in mind, in C,
you have no choice
but to obey this.
But in something like
Python and dynamic language,
like Python and Matlab, if
you're not thinking about this,
it's really easy to design
things so that it doesn't work,
so that it's not true.
So a classic example is
a square root function.
All right, so suppose I
pass an integer to it, OK?
So the square root of--
let's do square root
of 5, all right?
The result has to be
floating point number, right?
It's 2.23-- whatever.
So if I do square
root of 4, of course,
that square root is an integer.
But if I return an
integer for that type,
then it wouldn't be
type stable anymore.
Than the return value
type would depend
on the value of the input,
whether it's a perfect square
or not, all right?
So it was returned to
floating point value,
even if the input is an integer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you
have enough methods
to find for a bunch of different
types of lookup function?
Can that become really slow?
STEVEN JOHNSON: Well,
so the lookup comes--
it comes at compile time.
So it's really
kind of irrelevant.
At least if type
inference succeeds,
if type inference fails, then
it's runtime, it's slower.
But it's not like--
it's like a tree surge.
So it's not-- it's not as
slow as you might think.
But most of the time you
don't worry about that
because if you care
about performance
you want to arrange your code
so that type inference succeeds.
So you prototype maybe to--
this is something that you do
in performance optimization.
Like when you're prototyping,
you don't care about types,
you say x equals 3.
And the next line you
say x equals an array--
whatever.
But when you're
optimizing your code,
then, OK, you tweak
it a little bit
to make sure that things
don't change types willy nilly
and that the types
of function depend
on the types of the
arguments not on the values.
So, as I mentioned, square root
is what really confuses people
at first, is if you take
square root of minus 1,
you might think you should
get a complex value.
And instead, it gives
you an error, right?
And basically, what
are the choices here?
It could give you an error.
It could give you
a complex value.
But if it gave you
a complex value,
then the return
type of square root
would depend upon the value of
the input, not just the type.
So Matlab, for example, if you
take square root of minus 1,
it will happily give
you a complex number.
But as a result,
if you have Matlab,
Matlab has a compiler, right?
But it has many, many
challenges/ but one simple
thing to understand is if the
Matlab compiler suite sees
a square root function,
anywhere in your function,
even if it knows the
inputs that are real,
it doesn't know if the outputs
are complex or real unless it
can prove that the inputs
were positive or non-negative,
right?
And that means it could
then compile two code
pass for the output, all right?
But then suppose it
calls square root again
or some other function, right?
You quickly get a
combinatorial explosion
of possible code paths
because of possible types.
And so at some point,
you just give up
and put things in a box.
But as soon as you
put things in a box,
and you're looking
up types at runtime,
you're dead from a
performance perspective.
So Python, actually-- s if
you want a complex result
from square root, you have
to give it a complex input.
So in Julia, a complex
number, the I is actually m.
They decide I is too
useful for loop variables.
So I and J. So m is
the complex unit.
And if you take square
root of a complex input,
it gives you a complex output.
So Python actually
does the same thing.
So if in Python if
it takes square root
of a negative value,
it gives an error
unless you give it
a complex input.
But Python made other mistakes.
So, for example, in
Python, an integer
is guaranteed never to overflow.
If you add 11 plus 1 plus 1
over and over again in Python,
eventually overflow the
size of a 64-bit integer,
and Python will just
switch under the hood
to an arbitrary position
in an integer, which
seem like a nice idea
probably at the time.
And the rest in
Python is so slow
that the performance
cost of this test
makes no difference in
a typical Python code.
But it makes it very
difficult to compile.
Because that means if you have
integer inputs and you see x
plus 1 in Python, the compiler
cannot just compile that to one
instruction, because unless
you can somehow prove that x is
sufficiently small.
So in Julia, integer
arithmetic will overflow.
But the default integer
arithmetic it's 64 bits.
So in practice that
never overflows
unless you're doing
number theory.
And you usually know if
you're doing number theory,
and then use arbitrary
precision integers.
It was much worse in the days--
this is something
people worried a lot
before you were born when there
were 16-bit machines, right?
And integers, it's
really, really easy
to overflow 16 bits because
the biggest sine value is then
32,767, right?
So it's really easy
to overflow it.
So you're constantly
worrying about overflow.
And even 32 bits, the biggest
sign value is 2 billion.
It's really easy to overflow
that, even just counting bytes,
right?
You can have files that are
bigger than 2 gigabytes easily
nowadays.
So some people worried
about this all the time.
There were 64-bit integers.
Basically, 64-bit
integer will never
overflow if it's
counting objects
that exist in the real universe,
like bytes, or loop iterations,
or something like that.
So you just-- then you just
say, OK, it's either 64 bits,
or you're doing number theory.
You should big ints.
So OK.
So let me talk about--
the final thing I want to
talk about-- let's see,
how much [INAUDIBLE] good--
is defining our own types.
So this is the real test
of the language, right?
So it's easy to make
a language where
there is a certain
built-in set of functions
and built-in types, and
those things are fast.
So, for example, for
Python, there actually
is a compiler called numba that
does exactly what Julia does.
It looks at the arguments,
type specializes things,
and then calls llvm and
compiles it to fast code.
But it only works if you're
only container type as an NumPy
array and you're only scalar
type is one of the 12 scalar
types that NumPy supports.
If you have your own
user defined number type
or your own user
defined container type,
then it doesn't work.
And user-defined
container types,
it's probably easy to
understand why that's useful.
User defined number types
are extremely useful as well.
So, for example, there's
a package in Julia
that provides the number
type called dual numbers.
And those have the property
that if you pass them
into the function they compute
the function in its derivative.
And just a slightly different.
It basically carries around
function an derivative values
and has a slightly
different plus and times
and so forth that just do the
product rule and so forth.
And it just propagates
derivatives.
And then if you have Julia code,
like that Vandermonde function,
it will just compute
its derivative as well.
OK, so I want to be able
to find my own type.
So a very simple type
that I might want to add
would be points 2D vectors
in two space, right?
So, of course, I could have
an array of two values.
But an array is a really
heavyweight object
for just two values, right?
If I know at
compile time there's
two values that I don't
need to have a pointer to--
I can actually store
them in registers.
I I can unroll the loop
over these and everything
should be faster.
You can get an order
of magnitude and speed
by specializing on the number
of elements for small arrays
compared to just a general
ray data structure.
So let's make a point, OK?
So this is-- and I'm going to
go through several iterations,
starting with a slow iteration.
I'm going to define
a mutable struct.
OK, so this will
be a mutable object
where I can add a
[INAUDIBLE] point
that has two values x and y.
It can be of any type.
I'll define a plus
function that can add them.
And it does the
most obvious thing.
It adds the x components,
adds the y components.
I'll define a 0 function that's
the additive identity that
just returns the point 0, 0.
And then I can construct
an object Point34.
I can say 034 plus 0.56.
It works.
It can hold actually--
right now it's
very generic, and
probably too generic.
So they act like the real
part can be a floating point
number and the imaginary.
The x can be a floating
point number here
and the y is a complex
number of two integers,
or even I can make a
string and an array.
It doesn't even make sense.
So I probably should
have restricted
the types of x
and y a little bit
just to prevent the user
from putting in something
that makes no sense at all, OK?
So these things,
they can be anything.
So this type is not
ideal in several ways.
So let's think about how this
has to be stored in memory.
So this is a 0.1.
0.11, 3.7, right?
So in memory it's--
there is an x and there is a y.
But x and y can be of any type.
So that means they have
to be pointers to boxes.
There's pointer to
int 1 and there's
a pointer to a float
64, in this case, 3.7.
So oh, this already,
we know this
is not going to be good
news for performance.
And it's mutable.
So that mutable struct means
if I take p equals a point,
I can then say p dot x equals 7.
I can change the value, which
seems like a harmless thing
to do, but actually is a big
problem because, for example,
if I make an array
of a three piece,
and then I say p dot y equals
8, and I look at that array,
it has to change
the y component, OK?
So if I have a p,
or in general, if I
have a p that's
looking at that object,
if this is an object
you can mutate,
it means that if I have
another element, a q,
it's also pointing
the same object.
And I say p, p dot
x equals 4, then
q dot x had better also
before at that point.
So to have mutable semantics, to
have the semantics of something
you can change, and
other references
can see that change, that
means that this object has
to be stored in memory
on the heap as a pointer
to two objects so that
you have other pointer
to the same object,
and I mutate it,
and the other references see it.
It can't just be stuck in
a register or something
like that.
It has to be something that
other references can see.
So this is bad.
So if I have, so I
can call 0.1 dot aa
calls the constructor
element-wise.
A is this array of 10
to the 7 random numbers.
I was benchmarking them before.
That was taking 10
milliseconds, OK?
And I can sum it.
I can call the built-in
some function on this.
I can even call my
sum function on this
because it supports
a 0 function.
And so it supports a plus.
So here, I have an array.
If i just go back up, I
have an array here of 10
to the 7 values of type 0.1.
So the type of 0.1 is
attached to the array.
So the array and memory,
so I have an array of 0.1,
the one here means it's
a one-dimensional array.
There's also 2D,
3D, and so forth.
That looks like a 0.1 value,
a 0.1 value, a 0.1 value.
But each one of those now--
sorry-- has to be a
pointer to an x and a y,
which themselves are
pointers to boxes.
All right, so summing is
going to be really slow
because there's a lot
of pointer chasing.
It has to run time, check
what's the type of x,
what's the type of y.
And, in fact, it was.
It took instead of
10 milliseconds,
it took 500 or 600 milliseconds.
So to do better, we
need to do two things.
So, first of all,
x and y, we have
to be able to see what
type they are, OK?
It can't be just any
arbitrary old thing
that has to be a
pointer to a box, OK?
And the point object
has to be mutable.
It has to be something where
if I have p equals something,
q equals something, I
can't change p and expect q
to see it.
Otherwise, if it's
mutable, those semantics
have to be implemented as some
pointer to an object someplace.
Then you're dead.
So I can just say struct.
So struct now is not mutable.
It doesn't have the
mutable keyword.
And I can give the
arguments types.
I can say they're both flow 64.
And x and y are
both the same type.
They're both 64.
But floating point
numbers, I'll define
plus the same way, 0 the same
way, and now I can add them
and so forth.
But now if I make an
array of these things,
and if I say p dot x equals
6, it will give an error.
It says you can't
actually mutate.
Don't even try to mutate
it because we can't support
those semantics on this type.
But that means so that
type is actually--
if you look at look
at that in memory,
what the compiler
is allowed to do
and what it does do for this is
if you have an array of points
0.21, then it looks like just
the x value, the y value,
The value, the y
value, and so forth.
But each of these are
exactly one 8 byte flow 64.
And all the types are
known at compile time.
And so if I sum them, it should
take about 0.20 milliseconds,
right?
Because summing real
numbers was 10 milliseconds.
And this is twice as many
because you have to sum
the x's, sum the y's.
And let's benchmark it.
And let's see.
Oh, actually, some of the real
numbers took 5 milliseconds.
So something should
take about 10.
Let's see if that's still true.
Yeah, it took about 10.
So actually, the
compiler is smart enough.
So, first of all, it
stores this in line
as one big block,
consecutive block of memory.
And then when you sum them,
remember our sum function.
Well, this is the built-in sum.
But our sum function will
work in the same way.
The compiler-- llvm
will be smart enough
to say, oh, I can load
this into a register,
load y into a register,
call, have a tight loop where
I basically call one
instruction to sum the x's,
one instruction to sum
the y's, and then repeat.
And so it's about as
good as you could get.
But you paid a big price.
We've lost all
generality, right?
These can only be two 64-bit
floating point numbers.
I can't have two
single-precision numbers or--
this is like a struct
of two doubles in C.
So if I have to do this to
get performance in Julia,
then it would suck.
Basically, I'm
basically writing C code
in a slightly
higher level syntax.
I'm losing that benefit of
using a high level language.
So the way you get around
this is you define--
what you want is to define
something like this 0.2 type.
But you don't want to
define just one type.
You want to define a
whole family of types.
You want to define this for
two float 64s, two float 32s.
In fact, you want to define
an infinite family of types,
at two things of any type you
want as long as they're two
real numbers, two real types.
And so the way you do that in
Julia is a parametrized type.
This is called
parametric polymorphism.
It's similar to what you
see in C++ templates.
So now I have a struct.
It's not mutable--
Point3.
But the curly braces t.
It says it's
parametrized by type t.
So x and y--
I've restricted
it slightly here.
I've said x and y had
to be the same type.
I didn't have to do
that, but I could
have had two parameters,
one for the type of x, one
to the type of y.
But most the time you'd be
doing something like this,
you'd want them both
to be the same type.
But they could be both
64s, both float 32s,
both integers, whatever.
So t is any type that less than
colon means is a subtype of.
So t is any subtype of real.
It could be float 64.
It could be int 64.
It could be int 8.
It could be big float.
It could be a user defined type.
It doesn't care.
So this is really not--
it's a Point3 here.
It is a whole hierarchy.
So I'm not defining one type.
I'm defining a
whole set of types.
So Point3 is a set of types.
There's a point Point3 int 64.
There is a Point3 float
32, a float 64 and so on.
Infinitely, many types,
as many as you want,
and basically, it'll create
more types on the fly
just by instantiating.
So, for example, otherwise
it looks the same.
The plus function is
basically the same.
I add the x components,
the y components.
The 0 function is the same.
Except now I make sure there's
zeros of type t, whatever
that type is.
And now if I say
Point34, now I'm
instantiating a particular
instance of this.
And now that particular
instance of Point3 we'll have--
this is an abstract type.
We'll have one of
these concrete types.
And the concrete type
it has in this case
is a Point3 of two int 64s,
two 64-bit integers, OK?
And I can add them.
And actually, adding mixed
types will already work
because the plus, the
addition function here,
it works for any 2.3s.
I didn't say there had to
Point3s of the same type.
Any two of these, they don't
have to be two of these.
They could be one of
these and one of these.
And then it determines
the type of the result
by the type of the [INAUDIBLE]
it does type inference.
So if you have a point
Point3 of two int 64s
and Point3 of two float 32s, it
says, oh, p dot x is an int 64.
Q dot x is a full 64.
Oh, which plus
function do I call?
There is a plus function
from that mixing.
And it promotes the
result of flow 64.
So that means that
that sum is flow 64.
The other sum is flow 64.
Oh, then I'm creating
a Point3 of flow 64s.
So this kind of mixed promotion
is done automatically.
You can actually define your
own promotion rules in Julia
as well.
And I can make an array.
And so now if I have an
array of Point3 float 64,
so this type is attached
to the whole array.
And this is not an
arbitrary Point3.
It's a Point3 of two float 64s.
So it gets stored again as just
10 to the 7 elements of xy,
xy where each one
is 8 bytes 8 byes,
8 bytes, one after the other.
The compiler knows
all the types.
And when you submit, it knows
everything at compile time.
And it will sum to these things.
But I loaded this
into a register,
load this into a register called
one instruction-- add them.
And so the sum function
should be fast.
So we can call the
built-in sum function.
We can call our
own sum function.
Our own some function,
I didn't put SIMD here,
so it's going to
be twice as slow.
But Yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Will this
work with SIMD?
STEVEN JOHNSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
In fact, if you look, the
built-in sum function,
the built-in sum function
is implemented in Julia.
It just hasn't [INAUDIBLE]
SIMD on the sum.
So yeah.
llvm is smart enough that if you
give it a struct of two values
and load them--
and if you tell it that
you're adding these two
values to these two values these
two values to these two values,
it will actually use SIMD
instructions, I think.
Oh, maybe not.
No, wait.
Did my sum use SIMD?
I'm confused.
I thought it did.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
removed it.
STEVEN JOHNSON: I
thought I removed it.
Yeah, so maybe it's not
smart enough to use SIMD.
I've seen in some cases where
it's smart enough to use--
huh, yeah.
OK, so they're the same speed.
OK, no.
I take it back.
So maybe llvm is not
smart enough in this case
to use SIMD automatically.
We could try putting the
SIMD annotation there
and try it again.
But I thought it
was, but maybe not.
Let's see.
Let's put SIMD.
So redefine that.
And then just rerun this.
So it'll notice that I've
changed the definition.
It'll recompile it.
But the B time, since it
times at multiple times,
the first time it calls it, it's
slow because it's compiling it.
But it takes the minimum
over several times.
So let's see.
Yeah, this is the problem
in general with vectorizing
compilers if they're
not that smart if you're
using anything other than just
an array of an elementary data
type.
Yeah, no.
It didn't make any difference.
So I took it back.
So for more complicated
data structures,
you often have to use
SIMD structure explicitly.
And there is a way
to do that in Julia.
And there is a higher level
library on top of that.
You can basically credit a
tuple and then add things
and it will do
SIMD acceleration.
But yeah.
So anyway, so that's
the upside here.
There's a whole bunch of--
like the story of why Julia
can be compiled with fast code,
it's a combination of
lots of little things.
But there are a few big things.
One is that its specialized
thing is compile times.
But, of course, you could
do that in any language.
So that relies on
designing the language so
that you can do type inference.
It relies on having these
kind of parametrized types
and giving you a way
to talk about types
and attach types to other types.
So the array you notice
probably-- let's see--
and now that you understand
what these little braces mean,
you can see that the
array is defined in Julia
as another parametrized type.
It's parametrized by
the type of the element
and also by the dimensionality.
So it uses the same mechanism
to attach types to an array.
And you can have your own--
the array type in Julia
is implemented mostly in Julia.
And there are
other packages that
implement their
own types of arrays
that have the same performance.
One of the goals of Julia is to
build in as little as possible
so that there's not some
set of privileged types
that the compiler knows
about and everything else is
second class.
It's like user code is just
as good as the built-in code.
And, in fact, the
built-in code is mostly
just implemented in Julia.
There's a small core
that's implemented in C
for bootstrapping, basically.
Yeah.
So having parametrized types,
having another technicalities,
having all concrete
types are final in Julia.
A concrete type is something you
can actually store in memory.
So Point3864 is something
you can actually have, right?
An object of two
integers is that type.
So it is concrete, as
opposed to this thing.
This is an abstract type.
You can't actually
have one of these.
You can only have
one of the instances
of the concrete types.
So but there are no--
this is final.
It's not possible to
have a subtype of this
because if you could,
then you'd be dead
because this is an
array of these things.
If the compiler has to know it's
actually these things and not
some subtype of this, all right,
whereas in other languages,
like Python, you can have
subtypes of concrete types.
And so then even
if you said this
is an array of a
particular Python type,
it wouldn't really
know it's that type,
or it might be some
subtype of that.
That's one of the
reasons why you can't
implement NumPy in Python.
This is-- there's no way
to say this is really
that type and nothing else
in the language level.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Will this
compilation in Julia work?
STEVEN JOHNSON: Oh, yeah.
So and it's calling llvm.
So basically, the
stage is you call--
so there's a few passes.
OK, so and one of
the fun things is
you can actually
inspect all the passes
and almost intercept
all of them practically.
So, of course, typing
code like this,
first, it gets parsed, OK?
And you can macro those
things [INAUDIBLE]
actually are functions that
are called right after parsing.
They can just take
the parse code
and rewrite it arbitrarily.
So they can extend
the language that way.
But then it parsed, maybe
rewritten by a macro.
And then you get an
abstract syntax tree.
And then when you call it,
let's say f of 3, then says,
oh, x is an integer.
Int 64, it runs a
type inference pass.
It tries to figure out what's
the type of everything,
which version of plus
to call and so forth.
Then it decides whether
to inline some things.
And then once it's
done all that,
it spits out llvm byte
code, then calls llvm,
and compiles it to machine code.
And then it caches that some
place for the next time you
call, you call f of 4,
f with another integer.
It doesn't repeat
the same processes.
Notice it's cached.
So that's-- so yeah.
At the lowest level,
it's just the llvm.
So then there's tons of
things I haven't showed you.
So I haven't showed you--
I mentioned metaprogramming.
So it has this macro facility.
So you can basically
write syntax
that rewrites other
syntax, which is really
cool for code generation.
You can also intercept it
after the type inference phase.
You can write something called
the generated function that
basically takes--
because at parse time,
it knows how things are spelled.
And you can rewrite
how they're spelled.
But it doesn't know what
anything actually means.
It does knows x is a symbol.
It doesn't know x as
an integer-- whatever.
It just knows the spelling.
So when you actually compile
f of x, at that point,
it knows x is an integer.
And so you can write something
called a generator or a stage
function that basically
runs at that time and says,
oh, you told me x is an integer.
Now I'll rewrite the
code based on that.
And so this is
really useful for--
there's some cool facilities
for multidimensional arrays.
Because the dimensionality
of the array
is actually part of the type.
So you can say, oh, this is
a three-dimensional array.
I'll write three loops.
Oh, you have a
four-dimensional array.
I'll write four loops.
And it can rewrite the code
depending on the dimensionality
with code generation.
So you can have code
that basically generates
any number of nested
loops depending
on the types of the arguments.
And all the generation
is done in compiled time
after type inference.
So it knows the
dimensionality of the array.
And yeah, so there's lots
of fun things like that.
Of course, it has
parallel facilities.
They're not quite as advanced
as Cilk at this point,
but that's the direction
there they're heading.
There's no global interpreter
lock like in Python.
There's no interpreter.
So there's a threading facility.
And there's a pool of workers.
And you can thread a loop.
And the garbage collection
is threading aware.
So that's safe.
And they're gradually having
more and more powerful
run times, hopefully,
eventually hooking
into some of Professor
Leiserson's advanced threading
compiler, taper compiler,
or whatever it is.
And there's also--
most of what I
do in my research is more coarse
grained distributed memory
parallelism, so running on
supercomputers and stuff
like that.
And there's MPI.
There is a remote
procedure call library.
There's different
flavors of that.
But yeah.
So any other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you
implement the big number type?
STEVEN JOHNSON: The
big num type in Julia
is actually calling GIMP.
So that's one of those things.
Let me just-- let me
make a new notebook.
So if I say I know
big int 3, 3,000,
and then I'd say that
to the, say, factorial.
I think there's a built-in
factorial of that.
All right, so this is called
the big num type, right?
It's something where the number
of digits changes at run time.
So, of course, these
are orders of magnitude
slower than hardware things.
Basically, it has
to implement it
as a loop of digits
in some base.
And when you add
or multiply, you
have to loop over
those at runtime.
These big num libraries,
they are quite large
and heavily optimized.
And so nobody has
reimplemented one in Julia.
They're just calling out to
a C library called the GNU
multi-precision library.
And for floating
point values, there
is something called big float.
So big float of pi is
that I can actually--
let's set precision.
Big float to 1000.
That's 1,000 binary digits.
And then say big float of pi.
And [INAUDIBLE] more.
By the way, you might have-- so
I can have a variable alpha--
oops-- alpha hat
sub 2 equals 17.
That's allowed.
All that's happening
here is that Julia
allows almost arbitrary
unicode things for identifiers.
So I can have--
make it bigger so we can have
an identifier Koala, right?
So there's two issues here.
So one is just you have
a language that allows
those things as identifiers.
So Python 3 also allows
Unicode identifiers,
although I think Julia
out of all the existing--
the common languages--
it's probably
the widest unicode support.
Most languages only
allow a very narrow range
of unicode characters
for identifiers.
So Python would allow
the koala, but Python 3
would not allow
with alpha hat sub 2
because the numeric
subscript unicode
characters it doesn't allow.
The other thing is how
do you type these things.
And that's more of
an editor thing.
And so in Julia, we implemented
initially in the repl
and in Jupiter.
And now all the
editors support, you
can just to tab
completion of latex.
So I can type in
gamma, tab, and the tab
completes to the
unicode character.
I can say dot.
And it puts a dot over it
and backslash superscript 4.
And it puts a 4.
And that's allowed.
So it's quite nice.
So when I'm typing emails,
and I put equations in emails,
I go to the Julia rappel and
tab complete all my LaTeX
characters so that
I can put equations
in emails because It's
the easiest way to type
these Unicode math characters.
But yeah.
So IPython borrowed this.
So now do the same thing in
the IPython notebooks as well.
So it's really fun.
Because if you read old math
codes, especially old Fortran
codes or things, you
see lots of variables
that are named alpha hat
or something like that,
alpha hat underscore 3.
It's so much nicer to
have a variable that's
actually the alpha hat sub 3.
So that's cute.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Steve, thanks very much.
Thanks.
This was great.
[APPLAUSE]
We are, as Steve
mentioned, looking actually
at a project to merge the
Julia technology with the Cilk
technology.
And so we're right now in the
process of putting together
the grant proposal.
And if that gets funded,
there may be some UROPS.